hey everyone welcome back to the channel
today we are doing yet another video on
systems design we're going to be
building out an exchange so this is a
disclaimer right now because I can see
myself getting sued for this video down
the line God knows why but uh if my
current company ever wants to come after
me for making this one I'm going to make
two things very clear one is that I'm
absolutely just completely shamelessly
plagiarizing this video from another
Jane Street exchain Building video uh
which I found on YouTube um and I'm
going to link it so you can see how
badly I'm plagiarizing it and two is
that I work on absolutely nothing
similar to exchanges in my day-to-day
work in fact like 50% of it is adding
buttons to Trader goys so with all of
that being said please don't sue me I
haven't done anything wrong I'm just an
idiot on the internet for fun let's go
ahead and get into some systems design
all right let's go ahead and get into
things as we all know this wouldn't be a
Jordan has no life video unless there's
at least one kov and one foot pictures
bit uh in the beginning and so here it
is what is an change well at uh you know
really like broken down to its Essence
it's basically one person saying they're
willing to buy or sell something and
this case I'm selling my foot pictures
for $6 and then other people saying what
they would pay for it so in this case
Megan Fox might be willing to pay $5 but
that's not good enough for me I want six
Karina kov comes along because she's in
love with me pays $7 and now all of a
sudden we sell now depending on the
exchange who knows what price we're
actually going to sell at it'll be
somewhere between $6 and $7 but the gist
is when she's willing to pay more than
I'm asking for uh then we are good to
go so let's go ahead and formalize this
in some problem requirements number one
is that we want our exchange right so I
just had an open outcry exchange where
everyone's yelling which still does
actually exist however we're going to be
building ourselves an electronic
exchange so we're going to be matching
buyers and sellers of stock via a
computer the next thing that we want to
be doing is providing an ordered list of
all operations that everyone will
eventually agree on right it's not
enough for uh you know the exchange to
provide some ordered list of operations
and then maybe if it goes down some
other backup comes up and provides a
different order of operations that would
be bad uh it would mean that some trades
that people thought happened didn't
actually happen and uh then they would
get very very angry and we would have
legal issues so let's go ahead and make
sure that we agree on The Ordering of
things and number three is that in
addition to providing a total ordering
over everything we also want to provide
an ordered list of all act activities
per client right so if I'm uh you know
my Trading Company I want to know
exactly all of the trades uh and the
orders that I made and the cancels that
I made in the relatively correct order
that I made them with a sequence number
for each
great okay so let's go ahead and talk
about the first thing here which is
going to be the limit order book so in
the last uh video that I made on this
topic I'm very heavily plagiarizing off
myself I spent a lot of time uh trying
to dive into the algorithm that you
would actually use to do this and the
truth is that in of itself is a video
and it's not really a video for a
systems design series either I'm just
going to explain the highlevel overview
or algorithm of how the limit order book
works and then from there I think that
should be enough to get into this thing
further so all that exchange is really
doing is keeping track of bids and asks
where a bid is how much I'm willing to
pay and an ask is how much I'm willing
to sell a thing for so if we're talking
about GameStop stock I've got some bids
roaring Kitty is willing to pay $100 for
five units of GameStop stock my wife's
boyfriend is willing to pay $90 for 10
units of GameStop stock on the other
hand on the ask side maybe Citadel is
either shorting or already owns some
GameStop stock and they want $120 for
their 100 units of it so $120 per unit
basically Melvin Capital who as we know
got brutalized in the short squeeze
wants $130 for their 10 units of it so
hopefully this is starting to make sense
now as you can see as things are we're
not going to be making any trades but
all of a sudden maybe roaring Kitty
decides actually you know what I'm
willing to buy five units
for $30 what will actually happen and
let's say he doesn't just want five
units but now he wants 110 units he'll
trade with both
Citadel and now all of a sudden he
actually wants even more than that he'll
also trade with Melvin because he wanted
110 units and both of those prices are
going to work for him so the gist is
that we're going to see one or more
trades executed when there's a bid in an
ad ask where the bid price is greater
than or equal to an Ask price and it's
important to note that more than one
trade can be executed at once because
when we have something like that we need
to ensure atomicity right it shouldn't
be the case that I only hear about one
of those trades and not the others so
this is going to be important when it
comes to fault
tolerance okay so let's go ahead and
talk about our our matching engine
performance or rather a high level
overview of it right because the
matching engine is the thing that is
implementing this limit order book right
here and so we want to be able to make
sure that this thing is as fast as
possible there are many many millions if
not billions of orders being placed
every single day on one of these
exchanges and if they're taking a while
to get through or there's low throughput
you're just going to have a bunch of
orders coming back behind them and
eventually everything is going to stop
to a crawl nothing is going to get
executed so we want to be as fast as
humanly possible here so what can we do
to do that well the first thing that we
want to do is limit as much IO as we can
which basically means any additional
Network calls and any additional calls
to dis which basically means we're going
to be running everything locally in
memory now of course that doesn't mean
that it's all going to be
single-threaded we have seen like
certain databases which will do this
ideally we want to be avoiding locking
as much as humanly possible but there
are going to be some situations here
where we simply can't avoid locking and
we'll talk about those a little bit
later cool another thing to note is that
our matching engine is going to be
deterministic right based on everything
that I described in the above algorithm
it doesn't really matter exactly when
the message comes in just more so that
if a given message comes in right so
let's say we have some message M and we
have some limit order book State s when
we apply M to S we're always going to
get S Prime now of course this doesn't
necessarily mean that you know if M and
M Prime come to S at the same time uh
that you know regardless of the order
they're applied that we're going to get
the same S Prime that's not the case we
are going to have to order these
operations for us to make sure that our
state is consistent
cool so let's talk about some networking
as far as our matching engine is
concerned basically the gist is Right
we've got this one box which is our
matching engine and then we've got a
bunch of people who really really care
about what's going on in that matching
engine we've got all the clients right
so all of the the vanguards and the the
robin hoods and any other people that
are actually trading with the exchange
on behalf of customers sending these
orders we've got a bunch of Banks and
clearing companies who care for you know
verifying that things look good and then
we've just got other Market data vendors
maybe people like Bloomberg who are
getting this data modifying it a little
bit and then sending it out to other
people for money cool and the big thing
is that probably all of these people or
all these clients are going to be
connected to the matching engine through
proxy servers but the point is those
proxy servers need to be getting the
data delivered to them fairly right
because if the data goes to one of the
proxy servers well before the others
people are going to start complaining
about that quite a bit because it's not
like you know you're paying more money
to be connected to a certain proxy
server it's more so that you know we've
got a bunch of them they should be
delivering all of the market data at
around the same time otherwise if
someone gets Market data sooner than
someone else they have more information
than them and can make more money
trading and that is kind of the the gist
behind high frequency trading but the
point is we want to make this thing as
Fair as possible or we get in trouble so
the way that we do this and this is
mostly background here I wouldn't really
expect anyone like be able to Rattle
this off during a normal Tech interview
is we would use something like UDP
multicast the reason being that TCP
which is our go-to standard choice for
most web applications is going to
require us having a bunch of onetoone
connections from our actual exchange
itself and so if you have a bunch of
onetoone connections sure maybe you can
use multiple threads to send messages
out at similar times but they're not
going to go out at exactly the same time
whereas multicast is literally one
message that comes out of your computer
and then it basically gets forwarded
over that private Network that
everyone's connected to and uh
supposedly this is the most Fair
admittedly I don't know too much about
this network stuff I'm not going to
claim to either I would recommend
looking this one up more on your own if
you can uh I simply don't know so please
don't kill me in the comments cool so
what happens when we use UDP as opposed
to TCP well this much I do know we lose
a few nice features that TCP has for
starters we lose flow control we lose an
ordered broadcast and we also just lose
reliable broadcast so in UDP messages
can get just get dropped or they can be
delivered out of order or anything along
those lines it's really fair game that
you're basically just sending packets
willy-nilly over the network and
anything can
happen so how are we actually going to
deal with the fact that we're using UDP
well like I mentioned messages can come
out of order and they can be dropped uh
the flow control thing basically the
only way we're going to be able to deal
with that is by having consumers of
these messages that are sufficiently
fast the actual out of ordering and the
drop messages well we're going to deal
with that by using something called
retransmits so this is very much
something that gets actually used in you
know these actual exchange designs where
we're using UDP the reason being that
let's say you know I have a matching
engine and it sends out messages with
sequence numbers four and five so four
and five go out but for some reason our
client over here doesn't receive number
four it just gets number five and so
it's going to say shoot you know what I
saw everything up to sequence number
three and now I'm getting a sequence
number five which implies that a
sequence number four exists well
fortunately even though our client
dropped this message we've got a few
different retransmitter nodes which are
sitting over here solely for the purpose
of caching every single message and
basically putting it in its own log so
then as the client I can go to the
retransmitter and say hey I dropped a
message give me what I missed and so the
retransmitter is going to allow us to
make sure that we have all of these
messages and can deliver them back to
our client without actually risking
losing a bunch of data now is it
possible that somehow all of these
messages don't get to the retransmitter
uh I suppose so yes but that's why we
have a lot of retransmitter otherwise uh
you know the increasing uh there's an
increasing probability of something like
that happen
happening okay the next thing that we
are going to do is talk about the fault
tolerance of our matching engine because
right now what we've discussed is
everything important is pretty much
happening in here and so if I were to go
ahead and take it down via a nuke or via
a sweet 360 roundhouse kick uh we're in
trouble so what can we
do basically like we mentioned this
thing's running in memory so even if it
were to come back up we still don't have
our state restored we basically are
going to need a full-on backup in fact
we probably would even want multiple
backups but the gist is we're going to
have some sort of Zookeeper node right
something that you know we can achieve
consensus with where all of the nodes
and zookeeper you know constantly doing
heartbeats with our primary matching
engine and then if they all agree that
the primary has gone down then you would
go ahead and uh you know stop the heart
beating or and uh continue to basically
elect the backup as the new leader cool
so what are we going to do now uh we're
going to recreate this state so uh
basically how are we going to set up our
backup I'm going to present a couple of
options we'll talk about what's more
feasible than the others so option
number one is that you know we've got
our primary we've got our backup and for
the backup to get the same exact State
as our primary node what we can do is
have every single client who's sending
orders send them to both the primary and
the backup however this is going to be
problematic for a couple of reasons
let's imagine that we wanted to go ahead
and send uh you know an order to both
the primary and the backup what could
happen is if if we have two clients
sending orders to them their orders
could get interleaved right so what
might happen is that this guy's order
first hits the backup and then hits the
primary and in that same time this guy's
first order hits the primary and then
hits the backup and so basically what
you might have is that you know on the
primary it looks something like client
one's order gets executed first then
client two and over here on the backup
client twos order gets executed first
then Cent one and now these guys
basically disagree uh on you know what
the actual state of the thing is and
that is bad uh it's unacceptable and
like I mentioned if we disagree on you
know who traded first then we're going
to have discrepancies down the line and
people are going to get very mad because
then you know the primary goes down
client one thinks he traded first and
then all of a sudden we switch over to
the backup and now he seeing he traded
after client to he's going to be very
upset with that so cool what can we
actually do instead instead what we can
do is State machine replication so we've
talked about this before but this is
always something that's very useful when
you've got one node that's basically
processing every single thing in uh
memory and you know we need to continue
to process it quickly and so we can
basically just pop out all of the state
that it is processed and then process it
on the second note so I'll describe that
in more detail basically the gist is we
have our backup we're listening to the
output of the primary as opposed to the
inputs because the inputs can get there
in any order but the output is in a
sequenced order right we mentioned that
the primary matching engine is
outputting uh events with sequence
numbers meaning that on the backup we
can apply them in the same order as the
sequence numbers we don't even have to
uh get those messages in order on the
backup right because they might come to
the backup out of order but because they
have sequence numbers because we have
retransmitter nodes uh the backup is
always able to stay in perfect sync with
the primary so what is one Edge case
that could happen here well let's
imagine we have a client
the client puts in an order over here to
the primary and that triggers multiple
different trades like I mentioned right
so now all of a sudden we've got message
one message two and message three let's
say that you know the client or rather
the primary M matching engine delivers
message one and then it goes down before
message two and three are delivered now
that's bad because these three events
are supposed to be Atomic it doesn't
make sense to have message one unless
you also have message two and three the
fortunate thing is that all of these
messages are determined istic right so
when the backup sees message one it's
going to realize because it runs the
same exact code as the primary and sees
that it has to apply these operations
that oh you know what I didn't even
receive messages two and three but I
know those are about to happen because
they have to happen at the same time
cool so the backup is going to generate
two and three based off of number one
and the gist is that you know for
something like this to work we do still
need atomicity at the individual message
level so you know message one is itself
probably comprised of multiple different
internet packets and we need all of
these to arrive together for this thing
to count so what could we do well we
could have actual sequence numbers
within that individual uh you know
exchange published message we could have
a check sum to make sure the data is
valid you know we could have an end
marker right here to make sure that
we've received all of it where it says
you know the number of actual uh
sequences in that message so things like
that uh will ensure that we have
atomicity at an IND idual message
level cool the next thing that we want
to do is talk about partitioning right
so up to this point we've had one single
matching engine that everything goes
through and the problem there is that
that is effectively a bottleneck so what
can we do to actually scale it out well
we could do some form of partitioning so
the question is what do we actually want
to partition on well we probably can't
partition within the same symbol right
so for example for Apple stocks if all
of a sudden we decided like hey you know
some orders for Apple stock are going to
go on one node and some orders for Apple
stock are going to go on another node
that's not going to work because the
whole point of the exchange is we want
all orders for Apple stock to be able to
view one another and potentially trade
on one another if the price is right if
we're not giving people the best prices
they're not going to come to our
exchange and frankly it might be illegal
as well so that's not going to work you
might be able to actually have the
multiple partitions communicating with
one another but then like we mentioned
now we're introducing a bunch of
different networking calls and that's
going to slow things down down a lot and
probably be in feasible so the real way
that you're probably going to be doing
partitioning here is on a per symol
basis right so if we're trading Apple
Google and Tesla we can have one
matching engine for each of these the
problem is some people depending on
their trading strategies might actually
want to place orders that are Atomic
across these nodes right so maybe I want
to buy apple and sell Google at the same
time and so I place an order to do just
that or maybe I want to cancel my Apple
order at the same exact time as I cancel
my Google order because if one reaches
before before the other and one counts
and works and the other doesn't count
and work or maybe I traded one of those
stocks and didn't trade the other now I
have a bunch of exposure risk to one of
the stocks when I wanted to cancel both
so the gist is you know when we
partition like this and we have these
symbols across multiple partitions the
only way to actually make Atomic
transactions is to do something like a
two-phase commit and that's going to be
really slow and so we're probably not
even going to offer that in the first
place because it's just going to require
everyone else to wait on our distributed
transaction and that's not okay
the last piece of this thing is going to
be returning ordered messages for
clients so the gist is here that
basically the matching engine is going
to decide on a total ordering that
doesn't necessarily mean though that the
matching engine is going to execute
everything on a single thread it just
means that every single operation is
just going to get some number assigned
to it it is possible that there are a
bunch of concurrent operations that
don't conflict with one another and so
it doesn't really matter which sequence
number we give to which one of those the
point is they don't conflict confict
that being said even if they don't
directly conflict with one another right
there are some messages that we do want
ordered relative to one another and
typically that's going to be within a
single client so for example if I'm a
person who's interested in trading I
want to know whether you know the trade
that uh I placed happened before or
after I sent my Cancel message even if
they weren't directly conflicting with
one another so the gist over here is
that you know for every single message
we're going to send basically an ID with
that message we're going to associate a
lock with that relevant client ID so in
this case you know this would be like a
user 10 lock and then when I try and
cancel versus when the exchange is
trying to trade uh you know something
that I have basically now all of a
sudden we're going to use this lock to
determine a monotonically increasing
sequence number for my operations assign
it in this case and then send it back to
me the client so hopefully the main gist
here is just that you know it's not
enough to not lock on any two
transactions that don't Direct ly
conflict with one another if they're
within a same client and we have to
provide the client with ordered sequence
numbers then we're going to have to do
some additional locking there
too okay so let's go ahead and get
ourselves into a diagram to finish this
thing off the gist is I've got a bunch
of clients over here and like I
mentioned we don't want to uh directly
connect those with the exchange for a
bunch of reasons for starters they're
probably not on the same private Network
so that might complicate multicasting
but even additionally we do like having
order gateways as well to perform some
sort of rate limiting so you can't just
Spam The Exchange and take it down the
order Gateway can you know stop you via
a rate limiter and then within the
actual you know gateway to exchange
private network over here everyone's
communicating with UDP so the gist is
we've got our matching engine which is
really the center of every single thing
that we care about it's publishing to
all of these different nodes around
it with
UDP and then in addition we also have a
backup which is basically listening to
all of the primary messages establish
ing the same state as the primary based
off of them and then zookeeper which is
always waiting to hear if the primary
went down and if so basically saying
okay the backup can now go ahead and
claim itself as the primary then finally
we've got a couple of these
retransmitter nodes right here which are
also listening to the primary matching
engine basically all they're going to be
doing is creating a log of sequence
number to the actual message that the
primary put out and then that way if any
of these order gateways or the backup
exchange itself becomes a little behind
or drop some messages they can reach out
to one of the retransmitter nodes to see
if it's there anyways guys I hope you
enjoyed this video again for legal
reasons I plagiarize the out of
this from Jane Street it has absolutely
nothing to do with my actual work I am a
front-end button monkey and don't you
forget it anyways I hope we all have a
great night and I will see you in the
next one